presidente argentino opinó como la
propia vicepresidenta que este caso es
una cacería de brujas usted qué opina
no en realidad no es una cacería de
brujas porque a ver en definitiva lo que
se está llevando adelante es una
investigación de un proceso penal donde
se está buscando dos delitos
específicamente uno es asociación
ilícita es decir en el momento que la
vicepresidenta era presidenta en
república según el ministerio público
fiscal el fiscal se había llevado
adelante un proceso donde se buscaba
indefectiblemente
cometer delitos a partir de que a partir
de una empresa que se creó cuando asume
el presidente de kirchner el año 2003
esa empresa que se creó en el 2003 era
el medio dice el fiscal
el fiscal que que le imputó o le
solicitó estos 12 años más
inhabilitación perpetua que lo que hizo
fue que durante 12 años esa empresa
sirviera para hacer obra pública que es
ahora pública el estado le diera
prioridad para pagarle una vez que le
pagaba acá viene el disparador a otras
dos causas que tiene vicepresidenta una
es hotesur que es la causa de los
hoteles y la otra es la causa la ruta
del dinero acá y otra es la causa de los
cuadernos pero específicamente este es
en nuestro derecho se le dice el delito
precedente porque lo que se dé a partir
de este delito si se comprueba que
existe todos estos elementos que se le
están imputando situación ilícita y
defraudación del estado automáticamente
se permite y se podría comprobar qué
esta empresa llamada austral
construcciones que la empresa que
crearon a partir del año 2003 ésta es la
que con el alquiler de las habitaciones
de los hoteles de la familia kirchner le
devolvía el dinero que supuestamente era
mala vida no decir esta estera empleo
principal que había en esta cuestión
entonces automáticamente y el ministerio
público el fiscal lo que hace es pide la
pena pide esta pena de 12 años más
inhabilitación en base a distintos
elementos uno de ellos es a partir de la
reforma del 94 de la reforma
condicionado argentina en el año 94 se
incorporó al texto constitucional
el articulado
sobre los delitos de corrupción entonces
hay una protección constitucional y
disculpe abogado hay previsiones de la
sentencia que herramientas se le quedan
al ex presidenta y cuánto se podría
dilatar esta decisión si es que llega
una decisión final
a ver en realidad lo que lo que puede
pasar en definitiva es vos tenés que ver
el proceso ahora terminó la etapa
concluyó la etapa de el alegato de los
fiscales y ahora empieza toda la etapa
de la defensa ustedes no se olviden que
hay aproximadamente entre el 12 y 15
imputados cada uno de los abogados van a
tener que rebatir los argumentos del
fiscal y aproximadamente en el mes de
diciembre estaríamos o podríamos llegar
a hablar a que exista una sentencia por
el lado del tribunal por eso hoy por hoy
lo único que hay es un pedido del fiscal
no hay ninguna sentencia no hay fallo
alguno y después viene todo un proceso
que después viene la apelación y después
hasta llegar a la corte suprema de
justicia que aproximadamente sacando
cálculos podemos estar hablando dentro
de dos años tener una sentencia
definitiva a los delitos que se le
imputan o no a la ex presidenta de la
república actual vicepresidenta cristina
fernández de kirchner